when i was a child at the edge of the
galaxy
i heard stories about a man who could
forecast the future
but the story remained dark to me until
many years later
until it became my story
[Music]
until it became the only story listen i
gotta tell you you play harry selden he
is a man that can accurately predict the
future i think you are the acting
embodiment of this because everything
that you every project you are a part of
from the crown to the expanse to
chernobyl they're all successful
are you able to predict the future
and if not
how are you able to pick these roles and
why did you choose this one
i sadly nikki i cannot predict
future
um although i did predict someone would
ask me that question at one point during
the two days i hate
that i feel predictable okay
um
why don't i pick this role well
you know i uh
after chernobyl i was looking for
something to follow that up and you know
david he pitched me this story that was
this huge epic
sci-fi story that uh
unfolded over a thousand years across
the entire galaxy with this sort of
amazing uh
diverse cast of characters that took
place in all these different worlds and
that i was the
lead of and smack bang right in the
center of the story and
uh and they sent me the first two uh
episodes
and uh
yeah i was hooked they were so well
written i was
yeah i was on board
yeah it's incredible and i didn't get a
chance to ask david about this but maybe
you can speak to it because you have
worked on all these epic projects i mean
the crown that alone had a huge budget
this to me is visually one of the most
spectacular things i've ever seen and
you get a size sense of this size and
scope as an actor can you just speak to
how big a production this was how
ambitious it was and he pulled it off
yeah
a lot of people pulled it off
um yes but they i mean he was given the
uh the the resources to pull to pull it
off
and that's important because um you know
if you're trying to try and tell a story
of this size you have to be supported
you know so i'm and uh we are
we are aware of of of big storytelling
now so the bar is pretty high
um
i think the other thing that was
important was that the decisions that
david made was that he wanted as many of
the effects if you like to be practical
um so he he didn't want
we weren't acting on cgi sets you know
it was it was sets it was practical sets
it was real costumes real interaction
and um and that helps a lot as well
because it's got to feel grounded you
know it has to feel as though these
worlds could exist
so i've got to say by the way i'm just
loving
your
um the shade of your fingernails with
the plants behind you
i thought you were going to say my
jewelry that it's all cyclical no idea
because it's the color matches yeah it's
a nice little touch thank you very much
so let's see how predictable this
question is there is cloning there is
cloning in this series yeah if you were
to hang out with a clone of yourself do
you think you'd get along
and what age clone would you like to
hang out with yeah oh my lord
i didn't expect that response alone
would i like to hang out with myself
gosh
that's i
did not expect that question
um
you know
the younger jar was pretty hard headed i
don't know if
i i would get frustrated with uh
talking to somebody who thought they
knew
how to do it already um
i could certainly give them advice
though
um
yeah
okay that's a kind of tough question
what is the advice
well i i presumably other the patterns
of our life would be fairly similar and
i could i could try and help them avoid
some pitfalls
uh but uh yeah i'm not sure i don't know
i mean it depends on what mood he was in
like fungi would be good
you know
um
i think it can be pretty entertaining to
go out with and uh to go out on the town
with and have a few jars with yeah
sulky jared would not be good
okay got it and the age just the second
part of the question the age of what was
the age
either gold or you could go younger
whatever you choose yeah
well if i hung out with an older version
of myself i could maybe get some tips on
the future
you're familiar with my work psycho
history every mathematician has read
your theory it's not a theory
it's the future of mankind expressed in
numbers
and the empire won't like the future i
predict well you are such a breath of
fresh air in this series i loved
watching your performance a lot of this
series really revolves around gal
um there was one scene that it's such an
incredible series to look at it so i
can't even imagine what the budget was
but there's one scene where you're
holding your breath you're underwater
and there's this sort of water like
flowing around you wondering how long
you can hold your breath and if that was
a challenge or how did that go
i mean i
know my dad and my brothers are spear
fishermen so they kind of go underwater
and hold their breath the whole time
like literally my dad can hold his
breath for like three and a half minutes
i mean i'm making that up but i'm
assuming it's like that long because
they like died down meters like 25
meters ridiculous to fish yeah um so
that is something that i think
my dad kind of helped me out with like
how to hold my breath and do all that
like underwater stuff so that was really
really cool um it's i can't hold my
breath for long enough
yeah
but gail can hold her breath for a lot
longer so she's pretty impressive yeah
um well she is impressive and she's been
so updated from the books obviously
um can you talk about
that uh that aspect like did you source
anything from the book to get
inspiration from you for your character
in particular no i mean my character in
the books is not very fleshed out you
know it's very short
short and sweet
their appearance but um i think i'm very
grateful that my character is a lot more
fleshed out and has a lot more to her in
this series and i think it's super
important because she
you know introduces the audience to all
the characters and the story and kind of
the to all the worlds and she's the
constant voice that you hear i think
that's super important um because it
kind of has you know it's the singular
thread that kind of keeps all together
which is a great thing and hopefully has
the effect of
you know that it will keep things
together for the audience as well it
does definitely i'm wondering when you
first either read the books or found out
what was in the vault did you have any
idea did you guess correctly did you
were you on the right track i
was shocked i didn't read the books i
read the scripts before i read the books
so
i read the first book first couple i
think um but i i was literally i could
not put the script down i think it took
me
two days to read like 10 episodes worth
of scripts and it was just so brilliant
i was like in awe i was so so happy with
them um and the story is just insane i
was a fan before we even started filming
so
wow
yeah so of the script yeah there's a
line in um i think it's in the trailer
so it's not a spoiler but saying are you
happy so morning as an actress because
you did have so many scenes so many so
much range there's relationship there's
the epicness what was your happiest
moment as an actress filming
oh wow
the whole thing was unbelievable to me i
don't think
i think i did this thing it's funny i
recorded myself before at the beginning
of every day i have this little like
video diary on my phone so i can look
back and like see exactly what i had
that day and how i was feeling and all
that stuff and like every single one
even if i was tired i was like i'm just
so excited to do this and i'm just
excited to do that and i've done so much
more in
this one season than i could have ever
imagined i would have done in my whole
entire career so i'm happy i could yeah
this is great i'm so happy so last
question we know you can't tell us
what's in the vault what's one thing
that's definitely not in the vault
oh
one of gail's jackets is definitely not
those amazing outfits she's keeping all
of it she's got her hands on them she's
not let's go
history is littered with charlatans and
false messiahs
we should kill them
we can murder the man but what about the
movement brother
martyrs tend to have a long half-life i
have a really pressing question for you
what is with you in the color blue in
your characters
we're talking about ronin and now this
what is happening with you in this
country well i mean god you're really
getting right to the heart of matters
right here aren't you
you're right what is with the color blue
no but the real question is this is such
an incredible costume one of the most
amazing costumes i think i've ever seen
um i loved it it was mesmerizing it was
powerful like the first time you put it
on on set and and walked in how did that
inform your performance or did it
absolutely can i tell you a little
secret about the costume please
so do you know this it is powerful it
does project that thing one of our
inspirations for that armor was like
ancient ancient roman glass
do you know that the those very fragile
things that you'll see in the met museum
that blue there was a there's a there's
a a picture of a piece of glass that we
looked at that's a little bit opaque and
i think that that in a way unlocked a
key to what the emperor is
for me that it projects this kind of
extraordinary power but it's a very very
fragile thing wow
that that's i love that answer was did
was there ventilation at the bottom
though
of that costume
no no no no no no no there's no effort
towards comfort i mean that costume is
very is is not the most comfortable
costume i've ever worn i would kind of
end the day just being like
but that's the um
that feels appropriate to me you
shouldn't feel comfortable holding that
much power right you're right
but the other costumes i have are
extraordinarily comfortable and i
remember saying to the costume designers
like like i think it's like he's
he's not dressing for anyone you know
he's just like that's like like a thing
that people do in 2021 i'm just dressing
for myself i'm dressing for me um yeah i
have a question about cloning um
your play brother day there's brother
dawn brother dusk if you were to be
cloned in life do you think you would
get along with yourself
because the in this series you kind of
have to hang out with your clones and it
doesn't always go so well
no it doesn't go so well i mean i think
i you know
that felt pretty right when i was doing
it so to have to say the answer is on
some days i would hope to get along and
on a lot of days i think there would be
friction
um i think it's like that's one of the
things that i found most interesting
about him is that i'm not really playing
a character i'm playing a series of men
holding this role
right so
these these men whether they you know
and and now they don't they don't know
that they're individuals really what
they know is that they're the same man
but they're looking at
you know days looking at dusk saying i'm
going to do this better than you i feel
like i i i where you made mistakes i
will be great and he's looking at don
saying
you know
it's the galaxy
you know depends on you being exactly
like me
exactly following my footsteps to the
letter these are the lines this is the
blocking for the role you're about to
inhabit so okay so one of the big
mysteries of this series is what is in
the vault
i know you cannot tell me what is in the
vault but tell me something that is
definitely not in that vault
i would be afraid to say something right
now and then in a future season david
goyer's going to put it in the vault and
someone's going to call me a liar but a
cheeseburger probably isn't in that
vault like a really delicious perfect
cheeseburger right my mind is blown
because i almost just said to you what
about a cheeseburger that's why i'm like
flipping out right now
no no really yeah
you're serious i'm serious
so what's the plan
many years from now
if humanity is to climb from the ashes
the coming generations will need the
knowledge to build upon a foundation
everybody wants to know what is in the
vault it is such a big mystery a big
secret you're the only character that
can kind of get close but can you tell
me something that's definitely not in
the vault
i can tell you what is definitely not in
the bowl and that is a hot meal
um yeah no yeah the bolt is like a
proper enigma and um finding out what's
in it is going to be really exciting i
think for the audience well i think it's
like exciting
yeah really oh really
by the way episode six you ruined me so
much emotion incredible oh yeah
um so i'm wondering from you what did
you
uh because this is based on a series of
incredible novels
what was something that either you can
choose either you
definitely wanted to keep true to the
book in your performance or something
that you wanted to really bring to it in
2021 that would modernize it
um
i really love salvor's um like attitude
towards people and the way that devil's
super cocky and not afraid to speak
their mind and so i really enjoyed
bringing that to
to salvo um uh and i had many
opportunities to do it and trust me i
did it
you did and then i did i tried my best
anyway no absolutely amazing um part of
the premise of the show and it's so hard
to explain is
uh that it you know basically this
foundation is set up to
ensure the success of future generations
either through science through culture
if you were to put one item in your
foundation either a piece of art music a
movie
science a gadget what would you choose
i would choose actually no i actually
have what i would choose with me right
now oh my gosh okay i'm gonna choose
a uh a rubik's cube
because i think that they
they challenge you to like keep focused
and they always give you something new
to do because it's never the same every
time you solve it it's never the same
please solve it i can yeah can you
really if we had enough time i would how
fast can you do it
i can do it like one minute 45. but on
set on set loads of people on set would
like like saw that i could do rubik's
cube and someone who works in vfx like
they were they did it as well and so we
would sit there between takes and like
do the rubik's cube and then um see who
could do it fastest but i think i was
fastest actually one minute 45. well if
you brought it you i would hope that you
were the fastest i really wish we had
enough time i would just have you do it
but i know i still have um
i still have more questions um for you
so i know that when david pitched are
you gonna work on it this is amazing um
i know when david pitched this series to
apple he did it with one sentence and
got it sold with one sentence so you
know there's so many fans that are
excited about this series but for people
who don't know foundation what is one
sentence you would use
to sell it to the audience or describe
what foundation actually is because it's
so epic there's so many novels
i would say foundation is set in the
future
um in in a universe where there's a lot
of things going on and um
and humanity's at a breaking point
and there are a team of people who are
trying their best to ensure that
humanity continues you know existing and
it's emotional it's incredibly beautiful
there's human connection and there's
something for everyone
we must preserve only the most essential
pieces of civilization
deciding what is remembered
what is forgotten
first i wanted to ask you um this is
going to be such a cheesy junket
question but would you want to know your
future and the future if you had a
choice
oh no definitely not you wouldn't
no
no well i mean that's that's not going
to help you is it i mean
you start worrying about can i change it
can i not change it does that mean i
should do this opportunities to
second-guess yourself i think are not at
least what i would like to have i wanna
i'm like muddling around in blissful
ignorance
that was so british and so well put i
absolutely love it um harry selden plays
your adopted father in this and he is
supposed to be the most brilliant person
in the galaxy who is the most brilliant
person you yourself have ever met
oh goodness the most brilliant person
i've ever met
gosh that's that is that is
difficult
so many hands will come to your head
i've had the fortune to meet lots of
brilliant people i was thinking a good
answer would be my mum
oh my god i love it
i'm feeling good shout out to mom today
yeah exactly shout out to mum because i
went around today and
and she fed me and sent me away with
lots of little packets of food for me to
take home so
right now there's there's no brilliance
that shines brighter than hers ah well
let's talk about dads because um i was
talking to david and he told me that
actually um he promised his late father
that he was gonna make this series
um and that they wash it together as
kids given that you have like a
father-son relationship did that come
into play at all did he talk about that
and if not
um your character brings a lot of the
emotional resonance whether it be a
relationship father-son
love relationship talk about that sort
of bringing the emotionality to it
yeah i think it's important when you
have a story that
when you have a story that is so epic in
scope it's important to ground it in
those personal humane
interpersonal
elements do you know i mean i mean
that's something that i think gives us a
touchstone and a way into this world you
see that okay it looks different and the
technology is different and uh goodness
instead of our planet these people are
operating in a
galaxy people by
various different worlds with all sorts
of different cultures
but the thing we can connect with are
people going through their lives trying
to make the right choices trying to work
out where they
fit in this wider
cosmos i suppose i mean that there has
to be
a kind of emotional
resonance that we can tap into as an
audience i think not to just be
spectators sitting back going oh
goodness what what an amazing light show
right you know what i mean so um so it's
so it's lovely to have those
uh personal and kind of humane elements
in in in in rush you know for me to play
but i think it's it's not just inrush
you know that's that's one of the things
that really drew me to foundation
reading those scripts it was clear to me
there's a concern with the psychology of
the characters there's a concern with
their motivations their objectives what
they're going through
and and how we fit as individuals within
a kind of larger
system a larger structure whether that's
society whether that's
you know within within your job your
professional responsibilities racist
case he has responsibility to
uh to hurry both personal and
professional how do you juggle these
things right you know um i'm asking a
couple of people today uh basically the
foundation is something set up
uh to bring science and culture forward
for future generations to help them if
you could personally choose one thing to
put in your foundation movie book
song what have you what would you choose
ah this feels like a not very
imaginative answer but i'm gonna say it
all the same because i think it's
wonderful uh i would say the complete
works of shakespeare that sounds so
cheesy and so
like archetypally british but i'm doing
a production of romeo and juliet at the
minute so i get to
i get to say some of the most
wonderful words i i've ever read uh sort
of every night or every couple of you
know every couple of hours many times a
week so um it's fresh in my mind but i
think he writes with such humanity again
you know i think people think of him as
a great poet and these stories that we
all know and all the rest of it but you
know you go and watch a piece of
shakespeare or you sit down and you read
it and
i think you become aware of someone who
is really paying attention to the world
around him and how people navigate it
and that's the thing that is
encouraging
real quick um
going from shakespeare in this
incredible language and this incredible
scope of this show but if you could tell
the audience in one sentence
what is foundation about for the people
who don't know the books what would the
one sentence you would use be
foundation
is about
all sorts of people with different views
on how to do so
trying to save
mankind wars will be endless
thousand worlds reduced to cinders
change is frightening
especially to those in power
congratulations on this series
not only did you manage to make it so
epic but it also feels very intimate at
the same time my first question is i i
know that you pitched apple with one
sentence they said to you give us a one
sentence pitch and you sold it so what
is it do you think in this i'm i'm i'm
condensing the story but in the interest
of time what do you think it was that
had them go yeah we're doing this where
was it just your track record of being
such a great writer
um
i'd like to think some of it was my
track record uh i'd like to think some
of it was the foundation no pun intended
of the books
but um
it was just the idea of of doing a truly
epic
story that the audience a streamian
audience could dig their teeth into and
and something that was about family that
was about the future about about the you
know
sacrificing yourself for the human race
and and i just promised them
this is going to be emotional this is
going to be
this is going to make people cry this is
going to make people care
and fortunately i i think they were
happy with what we did
i mean not only that
i don't even know what kind of budget
you must have had because it is the most
spectacular series i've ever seen it is
gorgeous gorgeous um
talk a little bit more about that
because you did update these novels they
were written in the 1950s you swapped
the genders of some of the characters
you updated you modernized it you made
it sexier which i appreciated the
relationships like you have the emotion
but also give the fans what they want
here fans of the books what are they
going to get that they're going to love
that you paid homage to
i count myself as an enormous fan of the
books my father gave me the books when i
was 13 years old he said it was the
greatest piece of science fiction ever
written there was a tremendous amount of
responsibility on me personally before
he died
he made me vow that i would try to make
this and that's a true story
um
so uh but as as you said the
original novel was written in the late
40s early 50s it was reflecting a post
post-world war ii environment obviously
we live in a very different world and so
we have to in reflect the environment of
today
and that was the primary reason for
gender flipping some of the characters
because
we want uh the cast of foundation to
reflect our global audience
right um there are a lot of
i know that george lucas was inspired
also by these novels and there are a lot
of things that are inspired by star wars
but there are very few things that
inspired star wars i noticed a few
vehicles a very i mean you're you've
built an entire world that is so unique
but did you intentionally go okay
it is what it is because a few vehicles
and a few structures do look a little
star wars-esque
in a good way if you think if you think
of the broad science fiction that we
know of it's it's star wars star trek
maybe a little alien
and um it's it's difficult to get away
from some of those design influences i i
tried my best when we were designing
things a design would come in for a
vehicle or a spaceship and i would say
two star wars two star trek
two alien a couple of things snuck
through
and and and and don't get me wrong i
love star wars and star trek and alien
we tried our best to do something a
little different but but that's the high
wire act is this is a work that
influenced those works
and now is being brought to screen
you know 30 40 years after star wars 50
years after star trek um i think by and
large we were able to do something
fairly new and fairly groundbreaking but
but there are homages here and there
um one last question before we wrap i
know you said you have eight seasons
planned like 80 episodes basically in
success i don't want to be presumptuous
but yes if so um is there a character or
storyline for the fans of these novels
that you're most excited to explore
assuming that you move forward and after
watching it i have no doubt
it's moving forward
um i'm particularly intrigued to peel
back some of the onion layers of
demerizel's character
we are now staring down a barrel
of a crisis
this is the plan
i'm not turning around now
[Applause]
you